got a black coat because it's very venom
lavender shirts not at all so we haven't
a trailer for venom and whatever I say
in this trailer video that I'm doing
about venom doesn't negate what I've
said about the previous trailer videos
about venom cuz I'm looking forward to
venom and the things I liked any other
trailers they're here too
this trailer has a couple things though
I didn't like so i'mma talk about him I
just don't want you to think this is a
hate video I still think Tom Hardy was a
great pic as Eddie Brock I think he'll
do great in the movie in this movie that
reminds me of upgrade as Tom Hardy ish
did a good job in upgrade but basically
still looks like Eddie Brock uses Venom
symbiote and now he's just kind of he's
a victim of circumstance but he will end
up controlling this thing and being an
antihero I do find it weird he's
apologizing for it in this same
apologize that came at you they were
threatening you so you're sorry they'd
hurt you and they wouldn't say they're
sorry but this dude beat their asses and
snap some limbs I don't like the digital
projection venom face on his face though
don't lie it looks a little weird to
even shows him in the MRI machine where
he's all convulsing and freaking out
before you see the suit crawling up his
neck now it just projects on his face
the digital projection looks weird it
looks like a digital projection in a
sci-fi movie like if they did that thing
that some movies and shows do where
there's a lightning striking you see the
shadow of the monster half on their face
and there's no way a shadow like that
could happen but they're showing it
because they're foreshadowing that could
be cool is this not what this is those
looks like someone has a projector
they're like hold still Eddie all right
we're gonna project it on your face I
don't like that so much venom does say
turd though
I just want to say does that cell exist
in a comic book is there a speech bubble
in any venom comic book where he's like
[Music]
don't think of it in this trailer venom
just he says exactly what he's gonna do
a lot because they wanted to hear venom
say pancreas it was pancreas the most
threatening organ you can think of not
heart not brain which is what he eats in
the comic books ready you don't want him
to grab someone to be like brains but
maybe he could have just grabbed the
dude and simply said
[Music]
you don't have to list off the organs
describing how you're gonna hurt
somebody before you kill somebody just
doesn't seem effective what's the point
in seven seconds they're gonna be too
dead to care that does look like the
last shot of the movie though like it's
gonna have the music build up after that
or he doesn't there's a trailer just
fusing two scenes together I can see it
being the last shot never underestimate
Sony's ability to show you the last shot
of the movie in the trailer especially
when it comes to comic book movies and
at this point by the end of this trailer
it's kind of what I felt like I felt
like these trailers has shown me way too
much I already know the whole movie I
didn't know that dude was gonna be a
symbiote he was like a more greyish
venom I thought he was anti-venom and I
guess he's someone called riot and I got
posture
I know [ __ ] about right remember when
the rumor was Woody Harrelson was in
this movie and maybe he was gonna be
carnage who is Woody Harrelson in this
movie is he actually in this movie these
rumors get passed around so much in
videos I don't even know what's real or
not but if Woody Harrelson is in this
movie and if Woody Harrelson maybe is
Cletus Kasady he's probably in a
post-credits saying I just hope the
trailers didn't show me everything and I
just hope the movies good I'm hopeful
that it's good but all transparency if I
were in Vegas and it was like alright
you're gonna place your bet on whether
or not the venom movie is going to be
good or bad if you lose you lose the
money you bet if you win he'd double
your money I'd probably bet on it's
probably not gonna be good and I was
just what history's taught me but
fingers crossed I'm rooting for it right
so the new venom trailer in which venom
threatens with the words of have you
seen it what did you think about it
whatever you thought comment below let
me know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you wanna see more
click right here to see more
[Music]